YURI GRINSHTEYN: We've covered
using Cloud Trace to measure
latency on our
services and OpenCensus
to collect custom metro
telemetry already.
But what if you could
use a single library
to accomplish both?
Today, I'll introduce
you to OpenTelemetry,
the next major
release of OpenCensus,
and show you how to use it
for distributed tracing.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As our applications become more
complex and more services are
involved in serving user traffic
and completing transactions,
it becomes more and more
critical to understand
how requests
traverse our services
and how each service
contributes to overall latency.
This is what distributed
tracing does.
It captures the latency
of user requests
and how long it takes each
microservice in the path
to return a response.
The next release of OpenCensus
is merging the OpenTracing
project in a new open source
project called OpenTelemetry,
which provides a single set
of APIs, libraries, agents,
and collector services to
capture distributed traces
and metrics from
your application.
OpenTelemetry is a Cloud Native
Computing Foundation sandbox
project.
And I'm here today to show
you how to use it for tracing.
Let's start by
reviewing the basics.
These were originally described
in Google's research paper
on the Dapper Distributed
Tracing Framework.
We'll link to it below
if you'd like to read it.
When a user request comes in,
we want to create a trace--
the total of information
that describes how our system
responds to a user request.
Traces are composed of spans,
where each span represents
a specific request and
response pair involved
in serving the user request.
The parent span describes the
latency as observed by the end
user.
Each of the child
spans describes
how a particular service
in the distributed system
was called and responded with
latency information captured
for each.
Let's take a look
at a basic example.
We have a front-end service
that responds the user requests
and makes calls to
a backend service.
It has to wait on
that backend call
to complete to return the
response back to the user.
We want to trace
this interaction
to understand both total latency
and latency for each service.
In the frontend code,
we start tracing
and create the root span.
We then make a request
to the back end
with the appropriate context.
This is data embedded
in the HTTP headers
that our backend
can use to append
subsequent spans to our trace.
In the backend code,
we extract the context
on the incoming request and use
it to create additional spans.
This allows us to
explicitly measure
the latency of our
backend service.
Further, we can
create custom spans
if, for example, we want to time
how long specific backend tasks
might take.
When we look at trace
in the cloud console,
we can see our trace captured
with detailed information
about how long each step
in the interaction takes.
OpenTelemetry takes
it a step further
by exposing details about
the network interactions
between our services.
We can even see how long it
took to do the DNS resolution,
establish a connection.
I'm incredibly excited by the
promise of the OpenTelemetry
Project.
Next time, we'll
take a look at how
to use OpenTelemetry to get
a custom metric telemetry
from our services.
That's it for this episode.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]